La pregunta que nos hacen es,
¿cuántos estudiantes asistieron a la
escuela Einstein en el 2006?
Y en esta tabla, nos dicen que en el 2001
asistieron 150 estudiantes, en el 2002 asistieron
225 estudiantes y en 2003 se tenían 300,
pero si te das cuenta, no nos dicen cuantos
estudiantes hay en el 2006, así que creo que quieren que veamos el patrón de esta tabla,
¿y cuánto aumentó el número de estudiantes cada año?
Y con esto, podemos suponer que es el mismo patrón que se va a conservar hasta el año 2006.
Así, que si nosotros logramos averiguar cual
es el patrón de un año al año siguiente,
entonces podemos determinar la cantidad de
estudiantes en el 2004 y luego en el 2005
y luego en el 2006.
Y bueno, la suposición que estamos haciendo en este problema y que creo que el problema
quiere que hagamos, es que cualquiera que sea el patrón de crecimiento en estos tres años,
éste mismo va a continuar hasta el 2006.
Así que veamos qué es lo que sucede aquí.
Cuando damos un paso en este primer año,
¿qué pasa con la población de estudiantes?
Pues bueno, pasamos de 150 a 225 estudiantes,
y la forma más fácil de entender este patrón es,
cuantos estudiantes aumentamos cada año.
Por lo tanto,
¿cuánto tenemos de 150 a 225?
Pues aumentamos de 150 a 200, 50 estudiantes
y para llegar a 225 hay que aumentar otros
25 estudiantes más, así que por lo tanto,
hemos aumentado 75 estudiantes.
Y ahora, ¿cuánto hay de 225 a 300?
¿en cuántos estudiantes hemos aumentado?
Pues parece que otra vez 75 estudiantes, 75
más 225 es igual a 300,
entonces parece que aumentamos otros 75 estudiantes.
Así que el patrón es que cada año va a haber 75 estudiantes más que acudan a la escuela Einstein.
Y bueno, pues sigamos con el mismo patrón,
si sumamos otros 75 estudiantes,
entonces en el 2004 voy a tener 300 más 75 estudiantes, lo cual es 375.
Muy bien, ahora, en el 2005, si suponemos
que el patrón se mantiene,
tenemos que sumar otros 75 estudiantes y entonces ¿qué nos da?
Nos dará 450 estudiantes en el 2005 si suponemos
que el patrón sigue.
Y ya casi casi terminamos, si sumamos un último
75 para el 2006, entonces tengo 75 más 450,
si sumas 50 a 450 tienes 500 y con otros 25,
vamos a tener 525 estudiantes.
Así que esa debería ser la respuesta a la pregunta, si asumamos que el patrón sigue y se mantiene,
entonces en el año 2006 habrá 525
estudiantes en la escuela Einstein.